it's crowd one a pyramid scheme yes or
no sort of the defining issue of our
generation I mean it's really tough to
figure out there's a lot of competing
opinions you know obviously they're
going to third world countries that's
where a lot of their businesses and
they're getting people to sign up and
pay for $2,000 you know packages and
then they can sign up their friends for
$2,000 packages and everyone's property
right everyone's just making money right
everyone's just getting their friends to
buy in so the big question is is it a
pyramid scheme though a lot of opinions
you know this guy right here crowd one
is the name of the YouTube channel and
this guy put together a basically
two-hour presentation on a white crowd
one is not a scam using facts only crowd
one is not a scam and it's only the
facts this guy is a very big brain fake
news fake news and fake news and I'm
going to prove it with thanks and I'm
not sure I'm ready to tangle with them
but I'm gonna do my best I've put
together for you guys a comprehensive
report I've done all the work I've
looked at the investigation Norway did
in to crowd one I've looked at Namibia's
report and investigation guys I've done
all my homework and I've put together a
powerful presentation for you guys to
finally answer the question is it a
pyramid scheme honestly it's taken
everything I've had I've spent the last
basically year working on this so we're
finally ready to answer that question
let's get to it
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen my
name is tamas annum Kwanzaa aka bit
quite dead and proud car one business
owner I want to show you the power of
unloading your binary how to bail the
organization very fast this is you the
refinement is that you bring two people
and your final is active you get the two
to unlock their binary you get this - to
unlock their final is everyone who comes
on board brings - to unlock their final
is you get the slide to unlock their
final is you get everyone is getting
paid remember everyone is unlocking
their final is yet everyone is unlocking
their final is yet everyone is unlocking
their final is yet everyone lost their
final is yet it's money coming in it's
money coming in this money for everybody
who's in the organization everyone is
benefitting by the time you get to a
level five you would have made a lot of
money and everyone in this organization
would have made a lot of money if we can
be committed to bringing two people into
the business to unlock our violence then
we make a lot of money
thank you very much see you at the top
where you belong because it's too
crowded at the bottom it's a pyramid
scheme it's not a pyramid scheme it's a
reverse funnel system turn it upside
down
Oh